from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between kit kats in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
in japan our kitkats come in four sizes
big little pouch bite
and bar
and classy one sublime so one thing to
note here regarding mini sizes the
regular kitkat is 11.6 grams but the
flavored minutes such as matcha are said
to be slightly smaller 11.3 grams so i'm
gonna wet them now to confirm so let's
weigh a regular flavor kitkat first
it weighs 11 grams but it doesn't show
the decimal points it's just 11 grams
that's way
much matcha flavor
12. it's actually heavier than regular
flavor interesting japanese kitkats have
become popular all around the world in
the u.s of course is no exception i just
want to mention the top here we're going
to be talking about kitkats that are
native to our countries i know you can
get them online i think walmart.com has
some of them fantastic they're imported
we know thank you in the u.s our kitkats
come in nine sizes starting from the
smallest we have a kitkat minis
unwrapped then the fins
miniatures snack size standard
forefinger the big cat from there we
move up to
king size which is a piece accidentally
broke off and then i accidentally ate it
the big cat king size which looks like
just be two big cats and the biggest
size the xl
a bag of kitkat bites should have 11
bites let's count in japanese
each sound c
and according to the bag
the combined weight should be 50 grams
so let's weigh all 11 bites
it weighs
52 grams good deal
all of our u.s sizes come in a variety
of units depending on your kitkat needs
so many varieties here's a few worth
mentioning the minis the biggest bag of
minis unwrapped you can get is
grams as a title implies
these things are unwrapped little bites
it's sold like it's for sharing but get
real whoever sticks their hand in here
first it's their bag for the miniatures
according to amazon you can get up to
four pound bags aka 1814.37
grams and what it looks like they just
sent me
a bag that's loosely four pounds of
kitkat minis all the bars have their
various packs none of them seem unusual
i will however mention that the biggest
single purchase of a kitkat item you can
get is the king-size 24-pack the total
here is 2040 grams about 4.5
pounds of kit kat
here's all the kit-kats exclusive to the
us and here is all the kitkats native to
japan kitkat in japan is made by nestle
and is one of the best selling candies
in the country one of the reasons for
its popularity is that kitkat has a good
luck charm in japan because the name
kitkat in japanese is kitpokato and
kittokato sounds like
which means you will surely win so the
kitkat brand became associated with good
luck and these kitkats are often given
to students before their exams for the
past 10 years kitkat has introduced more
than 350 unique flavors wow some of them
are discontinued unfortunately and some
of them are original so we could get
them by the filming of this episode
so here are a few standard kitkat
flavors in japan coffee break but it
doesn't taste like coffee but goes well
with coffee
so i brought my coffee with me today so
let's see how it goes
it's actually pretty good much better
than expected so next we have
melon
it's so melon it has way too strong
melon flavor next we have chocolate
orange
overall not bad next graham cracker
this is fantastic next i'm gonna go
cheesecake
this is marvellous if you're a
cheesecake person like me you will
definitely like this next strawberry
cheesecake
you get some decent strawberry flavor
and cheesecake flavor at the same time
which is amazing next apple cinnamon
i'm no big fan of this there's a lot of
cinnamon in it which makes this horrible
pistachio look at this cute squirrel
kawaii
it's not great but not horrible either
next pudding
it's disgusting
it's way too sweet let's go next one we
have strawberry milk
holy crap
this is nasty
this is the worst one
so this is the last one i've got cookies
and cream
this is the best thing i've ever had in
my mouth
sorry to interrupt but believe it or not
the us does have a few exclusive flavors
you can't get in japan first up
pumpkin pie
yo this is exactly like pumpkin pie yeah
they hit it out of the park with that
one wow ki lime pie
this one's so good it tastes just like
key lime pie these are both fantastic
fruity cereal
what's what cereal is this is that fruit
loops tastes exactly like fruit loops
gingerbread
raspberry cream
i love this one yo joe
really
all right try it let's go what do you
guys think
yeah yeah starburst good call witch's
brew crispy wafers and marshmallow
flavored cream
you look great yeah it has like um a
frosting flavor to it i got uh glow in
the dark
wait what's supposed to glow in the dark
the packaging or the that's not fun i
thought this was going to glow in the
dark
the packaging let's see it let's give it
a shot
nothing's glowing all right lights back
on little red little quick crop
there's a regular how disappointing your
thumbs down
birthday cake
clothes like a frosting and sprinkles
flavor man they're all really good also
in the u.s you get a lemon crisp flavor
sold out everywhere it was like a
supreme drop
the second those hit the shelves are
gone also kitkat in the us has this line
called duo's
as you can see
three different flavors two flavors in
one we've got mint and dark chocolate
they're just like thin mints mocha and
chocolate eh i'm already i'm not
predicting this is gonna be anything
special
strawberry and dark chocolate is the way
i'm eating these annoying
i mean it's not terrible but the
strawberry and chocolate have been too
sweet with a dark chocolate into it so
these were fun right these were fun no
all right back to japan kitkat has a
collection of flavors inspired by the
many regions and prefectures of japan so
i'm gonna start with this mont fuji the
highest mountain in japan it's
3776 meters high and the flavor is
strawberry cheesecake flavor how can i
open this
here we go it looks great
it's pretty good but it tastes exactly
the same as the one that i tasted 10
minutes ago
alright next one is this
shinshu apple shinshu is kind of very
all the way to called nagano prefecture
and nagano prefecture is located in a
center of japan and is famous for
delicious apples and finally they turn
into kitkats
oh
this is the nicest chocolate i've ever
had next we have amaul strawberry so
it's basically from kyushu kyushu is
japan's third largest island and is
located southwest of japan and amaul is
the best brand of strawberries in japan
marvelous again next i'm going to go
with this one ito kyuemon ujimacha and
it
are named after uji city where they are
grown and the difference between matcha
and hojicha is moja is material much as
a green tea but hojicha is a roasted
green tea let's go with fuji matcha
first
matcha is always perfect how about
hojicha
it's as beautiful as my heart let's move
on to the next one we have benimo benimo
which is purple sweet potato it's from
okinawa so okinawa is japan's
southernmost prefecture and is famous
for benimo okinawa is my favorite place
in japan
i love this he has just right sweetness
we've got azuki sandwich flavor from
nagoya so nagoya is located in between
tokyo and osaka and it's famous for its
azuki sandwich azuki is sweet red bean
paste so sweet red bean paste sandwich
it's not my taste at all momiji manju
flavor it's from hiroshima so hiroshima
is located in the southwest of japan and
is famous for its momiji manju which is
kind of maple leaf shaped cake filled
with sweet bean paste
it tastes exactly the same as this one
sweet red bean paste japanese people
love sweet red bean paste hokkaido azuki
and strawberry flavor hokkaido is the
largest and northernmost prefecture in
japan and it's famous for its azuki
better than the other azuki flavors
why wasabi and it's from shizuoka and
shizuoka is located along the pacific
coast and is the top wasabi producing
region in japan
believe it or not it's actually pretty
good
let's go this one strawberry cheesecake
flavor again
it's from yokohama yokohama is located
next to tokyo but yokohama is not famous
for strawberry cheesecake i don't know
why they chose strawberry cheesecake
flavor for this
it tastes exactly the same same
next we have tokyo banana so tokyo
banana is a banana shaped sponge cake
with cream filling and it is very
popular souvenir of tokyo and they turn
into
cat cats
ta-da
it's gross when you come to tokyo you
should try poke bananas but you should
not try but talk about that kitkat rum
raisin
it's from
tokyo tokyo is not famous for ram racing
but says ramirez's gorgeousness and
fastness matches the image of tokyo
[Music]
there is a sort of rum i don't like it
it contains a lot of alcohol
last one sake flavor which is a japanese
traditional alcohol made from rice this
is a really interesting one
personally i like it and this is like an
acquired taste so when it comes to sake
flavor we were supposed to have yogurt
sake yuzu sake limited edition japan
sake umeshu but these were not available
at the time of filamentous and we have
kit kat desserts we have kitkat
colliders which i cannot find in the
filming of this but it looks to be
almost like vanilla flavored cups with
kitkat chunks broken up in it
oh man i had too much too many kitkats
and then we have these
these kitkats ice cream cones
i i hit a wall real hard
and a giant kit kat xl wall and i want i
officially did not want to do this
anymore
better but not by much more yeah so
that's it for the u.s sorry we have so
few flavors japan has a kitkat called
otonano amassa which translates to
sweetness for adults
don't let your kids watch this part
alright so it's a line of kitkat flavors
that are a little more bitter and less
with the regular kitkats so here we have
otona masa strawberry
white
and dark matcha
and dark chocolate right so let's give
it a try first this is just straight up
dark chocolate as you can imagine
strawberry
ooh
it's actually tart this is good all
right so let's move on to the next one
we've got dark matcha
this is so deep
much deeper than the other matter
flavors
so last one we've got otonano amazon
white chocolate
this is the best one among these otona
masa chocolates just right sweetness
alright so let's do matcha taste test
in japan matcha flavored kitkats are so
popular over the years we've introduced
13 different different different
different matcha flavors but currently
we were only able to get these three so
let's see how different they are first
dark matcha
deep matcha
was also deep ito among ujimacha
so freaking hard to tell the difference
but i'd say this one is the most
delicious one kyoto
we can get it in kyoto or order online
so here we have classy chocolates called
sublime so we have white sublime
and raw milk sublime and a volcanic
green sublime and orange volcanic sub
rhyme yellow ruby sublime alright so
let's try some out i'm getting sick of
the sweetness
it doesn't taste anything i was thinking
that you know like it tastes like
strawberry or raspberry or something but
did i get coffee confident
okay let's keep going alright so i'm
gonna go yellow volcanic volcano
this is the bitterest i've got orange
bitter
now i'm so scared green
sublime
it tastes exactly same as this too so
bitter next we have
milk sublime
it tastes exactly the same as regular
flavor i prefer this one last one i've
got white sublime
compared to the oto nanoamazon white
chocolate it's much better i'm done
hey guys it's harry i can't let you do a
kick episode without me because kitkats
were actually invented in the uk in
1935. they would eventually be
distributed by nestle across the uk the
eu and japan but in the u.s kitkats are
made and distributed by hershey's if you
watched our snickers episode you'll know
that there are some major taste
differences between the chocolate in the
uk and the us mostly that the uk's is
way better i'm do a three-way taste test
between uk us and also a japanese kitkat
to see if there's any major differences
between the three and harry thank you
for sending me this with your cute
handwriting thank you hari i get though
let's try uk kitkat first
the uk one is obviously the one i'm used
to the chocolate is very smooth not
overwhelmingly sweet and just very tasty
the uk is already like a lot richer
[Music]
okay okay can i try usb kitkat i also
couldn't find just a standard american
kitkat anywhere i guess we didn't bother
importing the regular one the closest
thing i could find was this kitkat duo's
mocha and chocolate one
something doesn't taste quite right
about that nope
uk
u.s they suck they both have too much
sugar joe harry try japan's kitchen
much smoother creamier in terms of
picking your favorite i think the us one
gets discounted immediately then between
the uk and the japan one it's kind of a
different style of kitkat i guess i
would say japan and uk are pretty neck
and neck they seem very similar japan's
kitkat is the best in the world
not eating too much candy
perhaps we can pinpoint the taste
difference to the ingredients in the u.s
a kitkat is made up of sugar wheat flour
our kitkats have the following
looking over the ingredients and notice
our kitkats have cocoa butter and
chocolate although it does not specify
what that chocolate is made up of do we
assume it is the same as the hershey's
chocolate bar i don't know whereas the
japan kitkat has cocoa mass cocoa butter
and cocoa powder now we're to believe
that nestle in japan holds their
chocolate to the same standards they do
in the uk it would mean that it would
have a higher fat and cocoa content
according to the uk rules a product must
contain no less than 25 coca salads to
be considered milk chocolate u.s
definitely does not go by this rule our
kitkat is made up of palm oil where
theirs is vegetable oil same in the uk
it is cheaper but is also worse in the
environment adding to deforestation
increasing greenhouse emissions and
water pollution so it is bad in the
environment and tastes worse fantastic
but good news for all you vegans nestle
has created a vegan kitkat with
substituted milk with a rice based
alternative but availability is
currently limited so they are not
available in the us or japan
this is a us kitkat miniature and is 8.5
grams the closest size we have the
japan's mini this is 42 calories 2.2
grams of fat 6 milligrams of sodium 5.8
grams of carbs four of those are sugar
and one gram of protein in japan the
mini is the most popular size it's 62
calories and 3.5 grams of fat 3.5 to
11.4 milligrams of sodium 8.99 to 19.4
grams of total carbs and 0.9 grams of
protein the most common kitkat size in
the u.s is the four finger bar 210
calories 11 grams of fat seven of those
are saturated 20 milligrams of sodium 28
grams of carbs 23 of those are sugar and
2 grams of protein the closest size we
have do that in japan is the kitkat bar
it contains 224 calories the most
calorie kitkat in the us we got is the
kitkat xl now i unwrapped it here so you
can see just how big it is it contains
640 calories the most calories you will
get in a kitkat in japan is the big
little pouch bite this bag is
275 calories